tom homan is here he's the former acting
ice director and a fox news contributor
good to see you we're gonna put a little
box with that bus there to see what
happens with that bus in the next little
while but let me get you to tackle two
topics uh here right off the top first
of all this idea that kamala harris
hated the the job of borders are didn't
like it one bit and the fact that
thousands of these illegal migrants are
being released into the united states
i'm sure that people south of the border
are looking at these pictures and saying
wow they're rolling out the welcome mat
well first of all the president's
comments that she was selected because
she's the most qualified
based on what when she was a senator she
voted for sanctuary city she voted to
limit ice authority she voted for open
borders so she's the most qualified to
sit down there and fail
because look they said they put her in
charge yet they want open borders they
don't want this fix because even today
you can't name one thing they have done
to slow the flow or to secure the border
and as far as
we just saw there is no lack of
detention beds look like we just
finished last fiscal year they're funded
for 34 000 beds their average daily
population and year is 19 which means
they left 25 000 beds empty now those
beds turn over every 30 days
so do the math that that's that's you
know
35 000 beds times three 350 000 beds
that could have filled over time and
what happened to remain in mexico
because we're seeing a lot of single
adults here that are being
released into the community i thought
they were supposed to be staying in
mexico while their asylum claims were
adjudicated that's another thing they
know we had to sue them to put remain in
mexico back i was a part of that lawsuit
and and we won
and when they they appealed it so that
they're implementing it about ten
percent of what we did they've only
they've only removed a few hundred we've
moved a few hundred an hour yeah so the
court needs to come back in and hold
them in contempt this administration
does not care about the laws of this
country now the statistics don't lie so
let's start putting some of those up on
the screen here first of all this is
customs and border protection encounters
for the month of february
2022 164
973 people were apprehended at the
border that compares to 101 099 in 2021
and 36 687
in 2020. where is this headed this year
tom
right now we're on the glide path to
beat last year's numbers the numbers are
the numbers are dwarfing last year's
numbers last year numbers were historic
the highest illegal immigration numbers
we've seen in history this country and
we're on a glide slope right now to beat
last year's numbers this this i've never
seen anything like this in my 35 years
and this administration is doing nothing
to address it or to stop it or control
the border now uh last time we had uh
yuan we were talking about this ice
report uh because this is the agency
that you used to head up it's typically
released in early december it was
finally released on march the 11th a
friday in the middle of a war it's a
great place to hide news if you want
here's the numbers 2021 arrests 74 082
that compares to 103 and 603 arrests in
2020 and 143 099 in 2019 in terms of
deportations 2021 59 0011 2020 it was
185 884 and 2019
267
258. isis mission clearly is being
diminished here that when i was a
director we enforced the law the three
years i ran ero we removed almost 1
million illegal aliens and what i see
today the secretary says it
re-prioritizes isis mission to
concentrate on criminals wrong because
you looked at the report they removed 48
percent they removed 64 less
54 percent less criminals than we did
last year and they arrested 48 percent
less so to say that they reprioritized
focus on criminals was a lie they
reprioritized because they're abolishing
the mission of ice and this report
clearly shows it ice at this point is
ineffective so so when you get these
these two lines on the graph both going
up and that is the number of border
encounters and the the the reduction in
enforcement
where where is that going to take us in
the next 12 months
you know again i've never seen anything
like this my career i mean this the less
people ice or wrestling moves it's just
another magnet for more people to come
if they think they can come to this
country and not be arrested and removed
because mayorka said being in this
country illegally is not enough to be
arrested that senate measures the whole
world come to the united states
violate the law of entering the country
illegally and you won't be arrested or
removed tom i have a sense that we're
going to be seeing a lot more of you
in the months ahead well let's hope so
can we explain to american people what's
going on there's no one else talking
about that other than fox good to have
you back in the studio thank you tom
homan hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else